[Música]
bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
France 24 Mi nombre es Luis Muñoz este 5
de marzo se cumple el décimo aniversario
de la muerte del expresidente venezolano
Hugo Rafael Chávez frías una figura
clave para entender la política
latinoamericana del siglo XXI y polémica
durante sus 14 años al frente de la
presidencia de Venezuela con motivo de
esta fecha en France 24 repasamos su
vida y su trayectoria Hugo Chávez tuvo
orígenes humildes Y desarrolló una
carrera militar durante su juventud pero
no fue conocido por los venezolanos y el
mundo hasta que en febrero de 1992
decidió dar un golpe de estado militar
para deponer al entonces presidente
Carlos Andrés Pérez Chávez lideró la
insurrección en Caracas pero fracasó en
la intentona y fue encarcelado durante
más de dos años por ello sin embargo su
popularidad se multiplicó entre millones
de venezolanos y al salir de prisión
comenzó una carrera política con un
enfoque biológico de izquierda así
hablaba en 1997 sobre sus motivos para
revelarse nosotros cuando nos alzamos en
armas más de diez mil soldados
republicanos hace ya más de cinco años
en Venezuela lo hicimos contra Un
gobierno que no hay que olvidar que
traicionó un país y que ya había
utilizado a las fuerzas armadas
venezolanas para masacrar a un pueblo
respaldado por esta popularidad Chávez
se presentó a las elecciones
presidenciales de 1998 bajo una
coalición de partidos de izquierda
llamada movimiento quinta República una
formación política que apostaba por un
cambio estructural de la Democracia
venezolana a través de un proceso
Constituyente y que llevaba la justicia
social por bandera Chávez defendió la
necesidad de ese cambio de modelo desde
una posición muy moderada en la que
incluso rechazó el socialismo o condenó
lo que calificó de Dictadura en Cuba el
objetivo es
refundar la República la constitución
del
uno está agonizando ya no no tiene
fuerza ni vigor propio para impulsar el
Estado la República y la sociedad el
éxito de Chávez fue contundente y logró
el 58% de los votos con los que se
convirtió en presidente e inició un
proceso Constituyente su Estilo informal
y cercano y la crítica dura contra sus
rivales a quien la población acusaba de
ser los responsables de la corrupción la
pobreza y la situación económica del
país multiplicaron la popularidad de
Chávez entre las clases obreras e
hicieron que su propuesta Constituyente
fuera aprobada en abril de 1999 con más
del 80% de los votos nacía así la
República bolivariana de Venezuela un
éxito al que le siguió una nueva
Victoria en el año 2000 tras un adelanto
electoral que le permitió al incipiente
chavismo tener mayoría parlamentaria
reforzado por las victorias electorales
Chávez emprendió una serie de reformas
sociales económicas y políticas
la ley habilitante que daba más poder al
presidente para probar decretos ley y la
promulgación de las polémicas 49 leyes
de Chávez agitaron El clima social y lo
enfrentaron con la oposición y la
confederación de empresarios fe de
cámaras hasta el punto de que se ejecutó
un golpe de estado contra el entonces
presidente en abril del 2002 durante
varios días Chávez fue detenido y el
presidente F de cámaras Pedro Carmona se
autoproclamó mandatario pero la
intentona también fracasó Chávez tomó
nota de este episodio y endureció su
discurso y sus políticas en el lustro
siguiente acompañado de un período de
crecimiento económico Venezuela comenzó
un proceso de expropiaciones y compra de
empresas para nacionalizar sectores
clave de la industria como el
petroquímico y socializó el campo a
través de confiscaciones de las tierras
que no fueran productivas sabes basó su
programa social en la exportación de
petróleo ayudado por el alto precio del
barril a inicio del siglo XXI su
política interna estuvo acompañada por
una presencia externa potente Chávez
lideró junto con otros presidentes
latinoamericanos como Lula da Silva o
Néstor kirchner la llamada Revolución
Rosa y mantuvo una fuerte disputa con
Estados Unidos y especialmente con el
expresidente George Bush a quien atacó
personalmente en varias ocasiones
Washington comenzó a ver a Venezuela
como un país enemigo y desde mediados de
la década de los 2000 comenzaron las
sanciones
ayer estuvo el aquí
en este mismo lugar huele a azufre
todavía
esta mesa
donde me ha tocado hablar tras su
reelección en 2006 Chávez focalizó sus
esfuerzos en conseguir la reelección
indefinida a través de un referendo algo
que logró en 2009 para esta época su
gobierno empezó a sentir las
consecuencias de la bajada del valor del
barril de petróleo y los indicadores
económicos comenzaron a ser
desfavorables por la elevada inflación
la deuda Estatal y la salida de
inversores del país una situación que
hizo que la oposición se reorganizara y
las críticas aumentaran críticas a las
que se sumaron otras por la
nacionalización y cierre de los medios
de comunicación críticos Durante este
tiempo de crisis el chavismo intentó
Resaltar los logros notables en materia
social y lucha contra la pobreza pero la
situación interna y externa comenzó a
ser cada vez más complicada algo a lo
que se sumó el diagnóstico de cáncer
colorrectal a Hugo Chávez quien decidió
tratarse en Cuba el tratamiento de su
enfermedad toda la vida política Pero
eso no impidió que fuese ganador en una
cuarta elección sin embargo el
mandatario no consiguió superar su
cáncer Chávez dejó Claro que de su
sucesor debía ser el entonces
vicepresidente Nicolás Maduro pero su
fallecimiento a los 58 años hizo que la
crispación política aumentara entre el
oficialismo y la oposición quién pidió
nuevas elecciones 10 años después el
chavismo sigue en el poder aunque los
años de Chávez quedan ya lejos en el
imaginario colectivo tras su muerte y
durante el gobierno de maduro Venezuela
ha sufrido una de las mayores crisis
inflacionarias de la historia El
chavismo ha sido aislado
internacionalmente durante años y casi
siete millones de venezolanos han tenido
que huir de su país por la pobreza con
esto concluimos Gracias por compartir y
comentar estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de France
24.com
[Música]